first of all welcome to the show but
more importantly welcome to the Grand
Chester this is your first participation
at the Grand chess tour how are you
feeling and how important is this
tournament for you
I'm
I'm feeling very nice to be here this is
my grandchester debut and of course I've
been following
pretty much all the grandchester events
and
yeah it's quite important to me I hope
to do well and
yeah put on a good performance you're
definitely doing just that it was a slow
first day for you obviously the first
game against Magnus that's always
difficult but you picked up the pace in
day two and you finished with two
important victories talk to us about
that about the change of mindset from
yesterday to today that helped you
yes today I would say it's a decent
start I mean losing against Magnus is
not something that should never happens
of course yeah after that I I could do
interesting games which I ended in a
draw I was feeling pretty good and
yeah today against rap boy I might have
had some chances and then in the end he
had this uh
can we let's see if we can put that game
that was round four if I'm not mistaken
yes so in the end
I think I was better at some point but
you were with the white pieces
just to give some background the story
oh yeah this crazy game yeah and he
actually had a win I think at some point
towards the end
yeah the window was quite nice I missed
look F3 and then
yeah yeah he had to go like talking F1
yes Bishop H3 but he has to go to keftu
first king even Rook back
I can play which phase three you know he
has some checks yeah
one
was it this I believe ah sorry there's a
bishop to H3 right yeah
exactly yeah and there's no Rook hanging
on it yeah this was uh yeah this was a
Miss win for him did you spot it during
the game no I didn't support it but I I
kind of felt that there should be
something because with the two Rooks and
merocon b4age
felt like there should be something that
I didn't see it but okay it was just a
Time scramble so that was fine and the
and then you get energy from this time
scrambles because you know you you get
the adrenaline running and everything
that comes with it
yeah I try not to go to time scrambles
because it's a bit too crazy for me but
yeah sometimes I land up there and
let's talk about the last game also
because uh I feel that one was quite
smooth and I really enjoyed your
conversion talk to us about this game
actually just missed Knight A5 which
which is just a corn blunder right
because B3 Queen F6 and
yeah
I'm sorry I think he has to take ed5
first
and then CD Queen answers
Knight C3 and uh
some somewhat still survivable actually
white is just fine okay I saw like
we hear Queen F6 Knight C3 was wasn't
sure about this though
this turns into a mess
you change down but you have great
compensation
that's why I didn't play B3 but uh
I just like admitted I made a mistake
and I was just trying to equalize
and uh
yeah here I saw a nice trick
so Rook D1 and yeah here I spotted he
has to go Queen C8 after which Bishop G4
yeah after which I probably have to do
this I mean and the end game is not
pleasant but it should be holdable yeah
maybe lose the P3 foreign
so even Queen F6 and I spotted this nice
trick with Queen E3 the point being
Bishop D5 have met before oh that's very
nice so here uh I already equalized that
I'm starting to get ambitious yeah and
queen Affair was just a bad word
because I I saw Mission B7 Bishop D4
right
but uh
you have some right D5 ideas yeah D5 was
the point
maybe he can go okay and then I saw
three convert
yes
no no more 95. very nice but he seems to
have made some mistakes along the way
perhaps already this Knight C4
he already he gave up a phone and night
safer was already quit yeah and now he
just became a matter of conversion yeah
and my conventional conversion was not
smooth but I think it was enough forever
good enough good enough uh gukesh
congratulations uh you're already used
to playing against all these uh great
players at such a young age
congratulations go get some rest and
we'll see you tomorrow yeah thank you
thank you Christian thank